so what a question for someone that
wanted to know what is the difference
between fasting and starvation okay
fasting is where you deplete your
glycogen reserves
that's the stored sugar in the liver and
the muscles okay and you're running on
fat fuel you have no hunger and you feel
great
okay that's what happens when you're
fasting when you're starving
you already depleted your glycogen and
now you're depleting your fat reserves
and you're running on your muscles and
your organs so your muscles and organs
are breaking down and you're using that
as fuel of course you're gonna have an
intense hunger and you're gonna feel
terrible okay so there's a huge
difference between fasting and starving
fasting is very healthy it's where you
repair this is where you break your body
down and of course you're also depleting
all your nutrients with this as well
here you're running on your reserve
nutrients now sometimes people feel bad
and they have intense hunger and they're
not really starving because the cells
have insulin resistance and that's
something completely different and their
bodies are running on sugar fuel so the
unless they eat there they're not going
to feel very good but when you actually
switch over to fat-burning doing fasting
and healthy keto you don't get this
intense hunger you feel actually really
really good your cravings go away okay
all right thanks for watching hey guys
so there's a whole bunch of people that
really need this information so press
the share button and let's get it way
out there